The Joe Rogan experience
with all this martial
arts skill Gwadar yeah,
but fatal is big fate or
might have like a gut,
but he's a thick motherfucker.
Okay.
Young fade or you ever see young
fade or when he was in his prime,
like back when he fought like
Fujita like back when, uh,
this is there's a picture
of fate or standing around
with a bunch of kettlebells
ever see that picture? Nope. I
was Fade Orleans lifting days,
I suspect. And this is
coming from, that's,
that's one when fader was fairly
young up there, but that's a,
that's not the one I'm talking about.
You know the one with the
kettlebells is that picture up?
See we found that picture never a six
pack in sight. No, no six pack. But um,
I suspect fade or might have been on
some performance enhancing substances
during his prime. You mean like hard
training? Lots of drilling technique. Uh,
set of steroids. Steroids. How dare
you sir. Dude, he was in pride.
Everybody was on steroids. Yeah, that's
him. Look at him. That's him in his prime.
That's a big mother fucker. Now, I
do not know if he was on anything,
but everybody else was, I
mean, literally everybody,
if they had it in their contract that you,
we will not test for steroids.
You know,
Ensign Nua told me that they
like essentially encouraged
people to take steroids.
Yeah. The pride days. That's right. Yeah.
And it's not like Russians don't have
a long history of using performance
enhancing substances. You,
I'm sure you saw that movie.
Um, ICARUS. Did you see it?
Yup. Fascinating. Right. It's, it's
a, it's fascinating. I mean, I don't,
uh, steroids often feel to me
like a bit of a witch hunt. Uh,
oftentimes you assume people
are on steroids. I'm a bit of a,
maybe I'm naive or an optimist,
but I tend to give people the benefit
of the doubt until proven otherwise.
But it, Chris obviously proves, yeah,
that everybody kind of throws a monkey
wrench of those gears. But you know,
with a, with fatal, the
technique and that technique,
the execution at the timing that brilliant
civil government, no doubt the heart.
Now he's phenomenal. Yeah. I just want to,
if not the greatest heavyweight of
all time, he certainly one of them.
And I don't think steroids would help
that. Yes, they do. To help. Okay. Yeah.
They held that guy particular yeah. They
help everything. They help your training,
they help you build your ability to
recover. They help your explosive power,
they help your speed, they help
everything that, but they also,
it's not just steroids, like
a lot of them on EPO, Epo,
radically in enhances your endurance.
Um,
and they're starting to catch people need
they just a stripped Tj Dillashaw the
UFC bantamweight champion for star
for a EPO or other, it's tragic.
Yes, it is tragic. Especially
Tj, you mean he's a,
just a phenomenal fighter.
If not,
I mean certainly top 10 pound for pound
and then this is one of those things
that comes up and you go,
Oh man,
so legacy killer and this world,
we have to kind of
reconsider what kind of a,
what should be allowed or not. Yeah,
no, I agree with that. That there,
there is an idea of where you should
make stair was legal right? Or not legal.
Sorry. Ah, a lot or some
kind of supplementation.
Like where's the line?
When you,
when you start to talk about the future
of martial arts, the future sport,
if you can control the levels
so that they're healthy. I mean,
isn't that the reason that they're
not allowed is because if abused,
they become unhealthy. Uh, they damaged
longterm wellbeing of the person.
There's, look, if that was the case,
we wouldn't allow fighting
because fighting is more
damaging than steroids for
sure.
For sure.
Getting punched and kicked and fucking
need in the face and elbowed into
consciousness that is way worse for
you than steroids. They're there.
The concern is not for the athlete,
the concerns for the opponent. Um,
the idea is that you will be able to
inflict punishment that you would not
ordinarily be able to inflict. You will
have more endurance. You have more power.
You will hurt someone potentially even.
Look,
there's going to be a time where someone
dies in a mixed martial arts in that,
and if that's someone who was
the victor who did not die,
it was on steroids.
It is going to be a huge national tragedy
and a massive disaster for the sport,
for everything. If that ever does
happen, we can only hope it never does,
but for sure you know,
it's a, it's a very,
very dangerous game you're
playing and when you are,
martial arts is a very dangerous game and
when you were enhancing your body with
chemicals that are illegal
while you're doing that game,
the real question is though,
here's my take on it and this is,
it's one of the most human
subjects and B being meaning,
meaning that it's messy.
Humans are messy,
like there's good and there's bad.
You know,
look like abortion is a messy
subject. It's messy. You
know, whether you have the,
whether you agree with someone's
right to have it or not, it is.
What you're doing is, especially as
the fetus gets older, it's messy.
You know, when it's a complicated
discussion, it's not a clear,
it's not like you should drink water.
You know what I mean? It's like,
it's a very complicated
discussion. Steroids are a
very complicated discussion.
You're not allowed to do them,
but they exist for a reason.
The reason why they exist
is there really effective,
they're really effective
at enhancing your body.
But how much of that will we allow?
We allow creatine,
we allow supplements in terms
of, you know, there's uh,
there's certain things that can slightly
elevate your testosterone slightly
elevate your growth hormone.
We allow sauna and ice baths and all
these things that have shown to enhance
recovery. But that's, that's too much.
It's too good there too effective.
But it's weird. It's weird that this
thing that we found that makes you better,
you can't use.
Yeah.
And so I have to go back a little bit
and disagree with you on something.
So in terms of fighting being dangerous,
and that's if we wanted to forbid things
that are dangerous for you would forbid
fighting. I think the main thing
you're doing can be dangerous, right?
The main thing that we're talking
about, the sport, the combat event,
that can be dangerous because that is
what we watch two people at the height of
their skill, ability, heart,
passion, putting their life at risk.
That can be dangerous, but
the supplementation around
it, the way to make it,
uh, to make their training better,
more effective, that can be dangerous.
And I thought that can't be named,
can't be dangerous.
So I thought steroids were
considered what sort of band?
Because abuses lead to
longterm damage to health.
Now we see steroids as cheating,
but it was banned initially
because it has detrimental effects.
Your that's true.
No, because there's no real
evidence that it's detrimental.
It's not as detrimental as alcohol
when you allow people to drink bit,
even a bit even when abused
where the bodies, like there's,
there's not a lot of like there's a
great documentary on it called bigger,
stronger, faster. And uh,
it's by my friend Chris Bell.
And when you watched that
documentary and you realize like, oh,
well the real negative consequences of
taking steroids or that it shuts down
your endocrine system,
so it stops your body's natural production
of testosterone and growth hormone
and hormones.
That's the real problem.
And for young people that can be very
devastating and it can lead to depression
and suicidal thoughts and all,
all,
all sorts of really bad things
when your testosterone shuts down.
But as far as like death boy,
I mean there's,
people are prescribed pain pills every
day of the week and fighters that are on
injuries, uh, that have been, you
know, that have gotten surgery, they,
they're prescribed pain pills everyday
of the week and those pain pills kill
people left and right.
That's just a fact.
People die of those things all the time,
much more so than die of steroids.
So I'm not advocating for the use of
steroids. Right? I'm just, um, I'm,
I'm being pretty objective
and neutral about this,
but I'm just looking at it like it is a,
it's a very messy
the subject. Yeah, that's
very eloquently put. But so,
so you're a problem in terms of damaging
the opponent is if one side takes Taro,
isn't that does exactly what happens
if both the problem you require
someone to do that maybe
someone's a holistic person.
They don't want to introduce any unnatural
exogenous steroids into their body.
And hormones in their body.
They want,
they want everything to be produced
by the human body. They want to,
they want to eat healthy food, train hard,
sleep well, and compete naturally. Yeah.
At CT Fletcher here yesterday, right? Yes.
Is natural bodybuilder or not bodybuilders
and power lifters. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But that's not required, right? This
is, you're not requiring people,
you're giving them the
choice. So, you know,
it's an interesting possibility where
in moderation you'll be able to last
steroids and future of athletics because
with an argument that if him and done
in moderation, you can actually create
healthier athletes. Yeah. That's,
I mean that's a real argument for the
Tour de France, the Tour de France,
they say that you actually are better
off in healthier taking steroids. Yeah.
And Epo. Then you are doing it without
it. Cause it's so unbelievable.
You're ruling on the body.
Yeah.
I mean those athletes are basically
some of the best people in the world at
suffering. Yeah. Longterm suffering. It's
incredible. Yeah. Ultra marathon runners,
all those guys. It's incredibly
different sort of thing. You know?
And you know the thing about ultra
marathon runners is didn't even test him
cause they're like, good luck.
Good luck. Those people have iron.
Will's like Courtney do. Walter's a
woman who, you know, she is. Yeah,
she's been in here. She eats candy.
Just drinks, beer, eat candy and pizza.
Makes Sense.
Yeah.
I mean she just got fucking iron will
or her will is indomitable and you could
take all the steroids you want
when you're running for three days.
That chick is going to beat you. She
just doesn't know how to quit. Yeah.
Just has no quit in.
Did you see the podcast with her
where she talked about how she fell?
She couldn't see. She
was in experiencing, uh,
I think it was inner ocular
hemorrhaging. Yeah. So her,
her eyeballs were bleeding internally,
something like that where it was
impeding her vision. She couldn't see,
I would stop. I would stop running.
No, she fell because you couldn't see,
busted her head open, bleeding all
down. Her face keeps running. Barely,
barely can see her feet as she's running,
keeps running.
I'm glad those people are out there.